[Applause]
[Music]
last month I introduced you to Halloween
in April well surprise May is going to
be another spooky one for you horror
fans too at least for a bit and then we
can all shoot guns and fight in the
streets make sure you're subscribed to
stay up to date on all the new releases
every week alrighty
time to stab some teenagers I'm talking
about Friday the 13th of course and if
you're a fan of the movies the game
should hit all the right notes for you
literally since movie composer Harry
Manfredini is handling the game
soundtrack to Kane Hodder arguably the
best actor to ever play Jason also did
the mocap here one player will become
the famous slasher while everyone else
plays as campers trying to survive the
night and Escape Crystal Lake do well
enough and one of you can even take on
the role of hero Tommy Jarvis Friday the
13th the game cuts into ps4 Xbox one and
PC on Friday May 26 yeah I know they
missed the obvious release date joke
there but it's better than waiting till
October if you'd rather take your time
with tactics then scramble around in a
dark campground then Disgaea five
complete should be more your speed this
switch version contains the original
game and every piece of DLC not a bad
way to kill time on the bus or on the
can
this entry expands on the series
trademarked tactics taking your unit
count from 10 heroes all the way up to
100 it also adds new hero types team-up
attacks a revenge system and a more
detailed hub that lists unit resistances
the original Disgaea 5 launched in 2015
but the complete edition comes to
Nintendo switch on Tuesday May 23rd do
you want a little more plot with your
shooters then get even or get get even
either way this game is part shooter
part thriller there's all sorts of plot
twists and meta virtual reality stuff so
you're never really sure what's real and
what's not the only way to find out is
to explore the game stark environments
and confront the psychological drama
with a healthy dose of bullets and
stealth takedowns there's a lot going on
and get even but you can start piecing
it all together on ps4 Xbox one and PC
on Friday May 26th so what about a game
with no combat at all in rhyme you can
explore an island and solve puzzles but
your only way to escape danger is by
running away there's a lot of mystery to
uncover here from environments too
painted murals but there looks to be a
lot of clever gameplay along the way
rime is a bit like journeying with a
pinch of the Last Guardian and a dash of
the witness and you can try it for
yourself on ps4 Xbox one and PC on May
26th with a Nintendo switch release plan
for this summer you can also check out
our own Jess MacDonald's thoughts on the
game through our video preview ok back
to punching people and it doesn't get
much better than altra Street Fighter 2
the final challengers brings the classic
2d fighter to Nintendo's switch
alongside two new characters evil Ryu
and violent Ken other new features
include the ability to flip between art
styles a first-person Hadouken mode and
two-player co-op fights of course you
can take the battles online too in both
casual and ranked modes Ultra Street
Fighter 2 the final challengers kicks
off on the 26th and those are the big
games we'll be playing this week tune in
to GameSpot for plenty of gameplay clips
from these and more
and as always remember that release
dates are based on retailer listings and
are subject to change
thanks for watching guys and I'll be
back with more games next week